from the tombs of ancient pharaohs to
the medals around Olympian's necks we
humans have long been mesmerized by gold
in fact it's hard to think of another
substance with such Universal appeal
in everything from Monarch's crowns to
Oscar winners statuettes gold screams
pre-eminence it's all over our culture
from Golden tickets to Gold discs from
golden handcuffs to Comedy gold
originally formed from the debris of
stars Gold's physical properties are
extraordinary it can be easily bent into
different shapes but has a much higher
melting point than tin or light it never
rusts or tarnishes and is a great
conductor making it perfect for
electronics tiny slivers are almost
certainly in your mobile phone
as Metals go it's pretty rare in fact
all the gold ever found in the world
could probably fit into a cube 23 meters
long on each side and this Rarity has
often made it popular as currency of
course you can't pay many bartenders
with gold coins nowadays but it's still
one of the safest assets to hold in a
market crash and Nations still hoard it
to prove their strength but take a
closer look at gold and its Crown begins
to slip we all love this stuff but we
love it too much just ask King Midas who
paid the price with his daughter
this Spanish conquistadors terrorized
the Americas for gold their brutality
towards the Incas Maya and Aztecs
delivered a hundred tons to Spanish
Kings worth around 5 billion pounds at
today's prices
most of it was melted down destroying
countless works of art and Jewelry
in the 19th century gold seduced men and
women in a different way as they hurried
to Wild Frontiers like California and
Southern Australia for gold rushes
although some did strike it lucky
Bernard Halterman discovered a gold
specimen weighing more than 289
kilograms in Australia in 1872. many
found only a few flakes while the real
fortunes were made by those selling them
shovels
indigenous people also suffered terribly
often attacked and forced off their land
to make way for this new industry golden
War often go hand in hand some conflicts
are fueled by gold disputes South
Africa's brutal Boer War of 1899 to 1902
being one example while in World War II
both the Nazis and the Japanese stole
huge quantities of gold much of it was
never recovered when States aren't
stealing gold robbers are
the biggest UK Heist was the brink smart
robbery of 1983 when six armed men
attacked a warehouse next to Heathrow
Airport they escaped with 6 800 gold
bars packed into 76 cardboard boxes
most of the gun were never caught and
most of the gold has yet to be recovered
thought that some of it was melted down
and mixed with copper tied its Origins
as well as being stolen and smuggled
gold is continually plundered from the
Earth gold mining is notoriously energy
intensive producing as much carbon each
year as the emissions from about 28
million cars unless it's done very
carefully mining can contaminate Rivers
wreck ecosystems and send highly toxic
pollutants like mercury into the air
unregulated small-scale mining also
lures millions of people many of them
children into dangerous work in some of
the world's poorest countries
so next time you want to add a little
bling to a loved one's birthday you
might want to consider the journey that
gold has been on Humanity's obsession
with his dazzling metal has driven us to
violence exploitation and destruction
perhaps if we appreciated Gold's dark
site we might use it more wisely
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video